I'm Ashton Bingham my name is Art Kulik
today we're here to answer your
questions from Twitter this is scam
support
[Music]
first up from All Things Tony how do
scam call centers even get our numbers I
literally never even give mine out this
is called Data harvesting and there's no
way to avoid it we have undercover
agents in India working for call center
and they literally told us so many times
that bosses of call center they will
send people to America so they can get
jobs at any database phone companies and
they will literally get all information
and sell it back to India all our data
is flying internationally you cannot do
nothing about it any newsletter you sign
up for any time you interact with a
business put your email your cell phone
your table reservation restaurant your
data is harvested and it's sold all the
time there's a lot more laws in place
now about you having to physically opt
in and have to consent to the data and
now the cookie approval like on every
website you have to accept it by you
doing that you are giving consent for
your activities online to be logged and
used against you for advertising data
lists that could be sold from company to
company and there are day data Brokers
that all have your information I'm like
I've never even heard of any of these
companies moving on strawberries
why do scam texts always have a spelling
or grammar mistake it's almost like they
do it on purpose to give you a little
clue it's very common to have
grammatical expelling mistakes I have
heard a theory and I don't think it's
too far-fetched that it is intentional
because they're trying to grasp a
particular person that would fall for
this and they don't want to waste their
time talking to someone
that would involve for this I don't know
if it's true I honestly I think it's
because they're all International you
know which is second third language and
they're just trying to find a way to get
your money and they're making a lot of
mistakes next up from Cody Sky how do
scam callers get paid hourly or
commission both both they have varying
sizes of operations from just a few
people in an apartment to literally five
thousand people on a staff in a major
business complex there is a opener
person who is opening the phone hi my
name is John Wilson and I'm here these
and these there is a closer so every
single position get paid different money
but the more you scam you're gonna get
commission you're gonna get bonus for
that so if you scammed an extra five
thousand dollars five thousand you'll
get an extra five thousand rupees as a
commission which honestly is kind of
sickening because it all goes to the
bosses it's like what 80 rupees per
dollar the boss is pulling millions
millions and millions of dollars on a
sometimes weekly basis next up the
Gregory Cole why do con artists use
WhatsApp coupled different reasons first
of all it's hard to track and it works
internationally without any barrier a
lot of these scammers are not in the
states and that's not to say there
aren't scammers in the States because
there are it's really easy they can just
claim a number they can do whatever they
got to do to text you there's really no
barrier to entry it doesn't cost them
any money it's free it's secure in the
sense that they know that they're never
going to be tracked or found out it's a
similar strategy to the robocall so
they'll put out billions of Fish Hooks
and even if a couple people grab them
they're basically waiting for you to
reply and say wrong number and once you
do they know it's an active number they
know they're talking to a person and
then they can start up a conversation
sometimes it might turn into a romance
scam sometimes they'll be like Oh wrong
number sorry I'm horny I forgot and
here's a picture of me naked send me
money to my cash app next up from
borrowed horses are there any good ways
to protect your parents from phone scams
communication and awareness is number
one we see it over and over and over
again these scammers are not just
technically Savvy they're professional
manipulators they will put pressure they
will find a weakness especially in an
older person that might be vulnerable
and they will push on that as hard as
they possibly can make sure you're
grandparents and your parents are aware
of the tricks a common scam that's now
taking a Resurgence is an IRS or a
social security scam my God which
targets the scams targets elderly people
hardcore because that one plays on the
fear they say that you're going to get
arrested because your social security
number was associated with some crimes
and we followed the car Toyota Corolla
22 pounds of cocaine uh blood and drugs
drugs and and your ID so what do you
want to do have them run things by you
or at least run it by somebody before
they give any information to anybody but
we also need to communicate that if you
were scammed you need to talk about it
like you need to tell people what
happened you need to tell people what
the tactics were that convinced you and
not feel shameful or or feel judged we
really want that those victims will step
up and show the world hey this is what
happened to me this is my story please
learn from this story and that's how you
protect your neighbors and uh your loved
ones next up it's not Kane somebody I
don't know accidentally privately
venmode me to 60 payments for burritos
and breakfast Fist and is asking for a
refund is this a scam yes absolutely yes
common scam especially through like cash
app and venmo money was sent to you from
a stolen credit card they request the
refund or the reimbursement and they
replace it with their own card and then
you send them the money may not
necessarily hurt you because it comes in
and goes out but it's their way of
basically laundering income through
somebody's stolen credit card back to
themselves next up from RC Lewin how do
I tell my uncle that the beautiful chick
he's talking to online is a man trying
to scam a huge amount of money without
him getting offended need suggestions
ASAP I think he can invest half a
million dollars
is that what that means oh my God good
on you for trying to find a way to
communicate it because that's really the
hardest part especially when they're
emotionally scammed over a long period
of time the best thing I can suggest is
not pushing on him any kind of judgment
or any kind of how could you believe
this or don't don't make him feel bad
for it just show him information show
him videos about this stuff about
romance scam specifically tell him to
try to talk to the person in a video
chat and I bet you this girl will have a
reason why she can't when they ask for
money when they ask for gift card
something we will send them a link when
they click the link we can get the
location that's why one person is saying
like hey I'm from Florida and uh when he
clicked the link guess what we got their
IP and we know that he's they're in you
know Nigeria next up is Alex bobskers I
like that name how do do you know it's
an apartment listing on Craigslist is a
scam asking for myself you got to look
for red flags if it's too good to be
true given the housing market price size
all that stuff six thousand square feet
and you have to pay 400 that's you know
New York Ocean View performance number
two is um we're traveling we cannot give
you keys if the rep you're talking to is
avoiding any kind of direct
communication or interaction with you
another red flag they're always going to
try to pressure you to act fast you got
to sign the lease now there's someone
else coming in with an offer like so
they want you to do it quickly but speak
to somebody on the phone and ask
questions next up from agenda 547 how do
people fall for scam sites so easily
like rule number one of the internet
don't click sketchy links how do you
forget anybody can be scammed and if you
don't believe me go to Jim Browning's
Channel he is considered the Godfather
of scambaiting he's a legend he was
scammed out of his own channel his whole
channel was deleted and he has a video
explaining how it happened it's
mind-blowing anybody can be scammed so
don't think for one minute that you're
above it because you think you're
smarter it's does doesn't work that way
next up 4-4 Jax four four what's the
most ridiculous scam you encountered we
have two different stories and it's just
like both of them are glorious you know
how how many scammers on Craigslist
right so me and Ashley we used to live
together we need to be Grouse we needed
to rent apartment this camera get back
to us and we already see red flags as a
scammer one bedroom apartment six feet
one bedroom
look at the pictures and pictures
so basically we told scammer that we
both astronauts from the space we
brought an alien with us and we asked if
is it okay to sign this lease agreement
these aliens will be living in in the
basement of this house they're gonna
breed it yeah you know we're gonna breed
it we're gonna make more aliens in our
basement but I just want to make sure
the neighbors aren't going to be
offended if there's some squealing yeah
no problem no problem okay that's
fantastic so uh skimmer said yes you can
breed more aliens in your basement just
give me your money flip side of that we
went to India in April to do a number of
things meet up with some of our brothers
that we've made some X scammers that
we've helped to change and reform their
lives but also to do some smuggling of
some glitter bombs in collaboration with
Mark Rober and Jim Browning essentially
we unleashed Mayhem on a few different
call centers it was only one problem we
got to recognize on day two and we
learned very quickly that there are
these telegram groups where scammers
will communicate with each other about a
certain type of scam someone posted in
that group hey we just saw astronaut
from Trilogy media here in sector five
they might be with FBI they're here to
hook us if you see them shoot them we
had to go into hiding it changed our
whole plan it almost scrapped the whole
operation but we were still able to make
it happen so we started with
Contraptions and Messi took him in his
backpack that had tons of cockroaches in
them and then he had a time delay stink
bombs he had smoke bombs rats in another
box and then we shipped the glitter
bombs in and then as soon as they open
of the owner of this call center and we
send that bomb and they open it moving
on Simo why are there so many scam call
centers in India I think it's just
demographics targeted with methods
that's why you see certain groups of
scams in certain areas of the world
outside romance it goes to Africa right
like tech support it goes to India we've
been to India we've seen it firsthand
we're very close with a lot of people
amazing people from India and they hate
the scammers just as much as we do next
up Megan the nft okay but the real
question is how do we scam the scammers
back this is right in our wheelhouse
because this is what we do every single
day we love to waste the scammers time
as much as possible because that's
that's really the root of what this all
is time costs them money they have
agents actively working talking to you
on the phone we'll talk to them on the
phone for three four five hours
sometimes we're learning about their
scam because throughout the process
they're doing all of their tactics all
of their things that usually make people
fall for it when it works so we learn
what those things are when we make the
content whether it's a video or a live
stream people can then watch those
things and know what to look for and
then thirdly the more time they're on
the phone with us is the less time
they're on the phone with your
grandmother and they're talking to us as
our characters we do have characters
speaking English what is that what is
your stuff this is a character we have a
voice changer we can do females we can
do males we can be young old who is this
this is Diana diagonal tall wig glasses
and a cigarette and it's very snarky
this is all godzillovich people always
ask why the hell do you wear wigs if
you're just talking to them on the phone
but it's like why not yeah you should
just do the rest of the interview
so anyways different personalities
different uh characters moving on Chris
the fist why is Western Union a scam
well first of all Western Union it's not
a scam Western Union as a company I
don't believe it has nefarious
intentions I'll explain why they're
associated with the word scam is because
they send money internationally it's a
very common way for overseas scammers to
accept money that they can get a cash
pick up really easily at a location from
a victim and once the money is sent
they're never going to get it back so
it's really good for the scammers in the
sense that it's reliable and they know
that they can get cash very fast next up
a green photog how do I get the IRS scam
people to stop calling me 10 times a day
you cannot probably nothing you can do
yeah keep blocking keep reporting
ftc.gov they got a ton of information
about which scams are going on and then
just you know block unknown numbers from
your phone if you're not in a line of
work that needs to receive unknown phone
numbers then don't answer them they need
to get a hold of you they'll leave them
a message next up Laura prolongo do
catfish scammers ever go to jail or Nah
Nah the answer is usually not especially
with catfish scammers because it's a
totally different type of scam and their
identity is usually a lot harder to get
for catfish scans it's it's usually
starts on dating websites Plenty of Fish
grinder I mean anything essentially
they're pretending to be somebody else
often times they're in the military or
they're doing something that makes them
like I live in the United States but I'm
not there now they eventually convince
the victim that they're in a
relationship and then they will need
money for something oh my plane got
canceled I need to book another flight
oh I there's no water here in the
village that I'm helping and why Keith
got diseases my teeth got sick usually
smaller amounts over multiple times over
a long period of time as long as they
can keep the victim hooked in fact the
scammer we're going to confront here
tomorrow morning it's a cash mule that
lives in New York he's been receiving
money from this woman who believes she's
in a relationship with this guy in
Africa for over eight years and she
sends almost the entirety of her social
security check every month to this mule
and she lives here in New York
Plaza plasma plasma sorry plasma she
doesn't have a plaza so she's easily
sent this guy probably over a quarter
million dollars yeah and it's all going
through this guy in New York who were
going to his store tomorrow morning all
right next up from Fulani Tudor why are
scammers rude after they get caught when
we disrupt their operation it makes them
mad and makes the bosses mad too because
no one's making any money they're very
nasty they're gonna blast you every
single word every single they want to
beep every single person in your family
your mom your everything they always
hate our moms they always want to do
something with your mom next up from
Auntie Becks is it just me or has there
been an increase in scans lately calls
links texts everything yes it's not just
you anti-backs especially what happened
recently with pandemic scammers love
when there is some instabilities people
need jobs people need money people are
hungry people have power outages
anything like that that they can use to
reel you in to either help you or change
your life is enough of a kick to get you
to go get some gift cards so yes there's
a huge increase in stands it's not just
you be on the lookout be careful all
right next from wuji and why do romance
scammers always pose as American
military dudes I don't get it it's a
common story because it allows them to
play the excuse of traveling often and
being away and being unavailable because
the scammer usually is in a different
part of the world so they need an excuse
as to why they're talking at odd hours
why they can't video chat why their
connection is bad and why they can't
visit them next up Beau black 98 why did
the Nigerian prince scam work so well so
the Nigerian print scam as it's been
coined starts with an email so you get
an email to your spam folder that says
hi I am so and so I'm a prince in
Nigeria and I have all this money and
it's yours quiet of course you know for
me to ship it to you sometimes it's cash
sometimes it's Consignment boxes with
gold bricks but for me to ship it to you
you got to pay an activation fee
scammers and I say this every time as to
why they're so effective they prey on
one of two things sometimes both which
is either fear of something happening to
you or playing towards your dreams of
things you want to happen to you and of
course everyone wants 65 billion dollars
to be sent to them from a Nigerian
princess Vault and finally tetagorg dog
how do I block scam life from calling me
what's up dog hey the scam likely thing
is a good thing because that's somewhat
recent whereas before you would always
just get a phone number and you wouldn't
know if it's scam likely there are lots
of apps you can use one we personally
use it's called Robo killer and it
allows you to not only block the call
but it'll answer it on your behalf and
waste their time with pre-recorded
answer Bots that you can actually find
us in which is really fun you can also
too just block like if it's not a number
in my contacts it doesn't even ring like
it'll go straight to voicemail well
that's all the questions for today we're
really hoping that you learned something
from our questions thank you for
watching and until next time until next
time
[Music]